the cities are on life support that's
the focus of tonight's
angle liberals always claim to love
urban life they love mass transportation
Chic restaurants you know theaters music
venues it's all so cool the vibrant
Social
Scene but why kill what you love and
that's exactly what Liberals are doing
and they wonder why life in San
Francisco Baltimore Chicago and DC has
become so unlivable well when they
wonder that they should look in the
mirror because they're responsible for
the slow death of urban America high
taxes high crime low office occupancy
lousy schools this is the cartet of
forces inflicted on our cities by
politician activists you know the same
people who often float unscathed above
the wreckage that they themselves
created and to cover for their own
failures they pepper their uh public
comments with appeals to phrases like
racial equity and reimagine policing
that's my favorite but vapid social
justice jargon just doesn't hide the
fact that their own policies are driving
away good people and great
businesses once bustling cities are now
struggling and then with an eroding tax
base it's lights out now the windy city
is now just one big swirl of crime with
Thug so determined that they'll use cars
as weapons to gain access to what they
want like this Jeep SUV here now even
concrete barriers aren't
deterrence of course store owners become
repeat victims in this case and they're
fed up this is probably overall our
seventh or eighth Breakin in the last
year or two and you know a lot of people
think insurance is easy to get but you
know now you know they're they're
tightened up and it's hard for us see to
get any kind of insur so all this all
this will be coming out of pocket and
Democrats can't even get it together to
control control crime when they have
popular sports franchises in their major
cities according to a sports book report
39% of those survey say that they've
seen or have been a victim of at least
one crime in areas near their NFL team
stadiums the most dangerous Stadium
areas may surprise you Denver topped the
place with the most crime s for 1,000
people next it was Seattle then it was
Detroit Minneapolis and Kansas
City now entrepreneurs they want to be
in cities why because there's lots of
foot traffic young professionals hungry
for entertainment lots of disposable
income but if a city refuses to ensure
Safe Streets and if they tell government
workers oh it's fine to work from home
fewer consumers are going to want to
spend money and time there and that
means businesses have less income and
when you have to factor in the high cost
of doing business these days eventually
the bubble
bursts DC restaurant owners are sounding
the alarm we have 11 locations in in DC
and over the past year each one of those
locations has been affected by some kind
of crime we now have to spend uh about
$4,000 a week on private security how
much more are you spending on security
than you did in years previous
it's probably about 20 to 25% more right
now we'll see where it goes in theut the
total well I'm involved in four
restaurants family-owned restaurants
here in the district and over
$225,000 a year we spend on
$225,000 a year how is that sustainable
but like many Lefty Mayors DC mayor
Muriel Bowser's answer to these concerns
about crime it just downplay the the
problem our experience with crime is
kind of a blip uh it's a phenomenon and
we can look back over the the last
several years and see a lot of
contributing factors um but we will
drive it it down uh that takes my breath
away now politicians May lie but numbers
don't check out the crime increases
year-to date homicides up 34% in DC
robbery 69% motor vehicle theft is up a
staggering 80 9% and total violent crime
this is terrifying is up
40% now Tam Muriel Bowser that qualifies
as a
blip well I don't think the Washington
Capitals owner Ted Leona shares that
opinion Virginia governor Glenn yunan
announced today that he struck a deal
with the franchise owner to move both
his NHL and his NBA teams to Northern
Virginia they'll get new facilities a
favorable tax deal and maybe in a far
safer Community for fans and players
well today a prominent DC radio host
explained what happened to lead up to
this and how much damage it's going to
cause he said I keep coming back to an
anecdote I saw on the Washington Post in
November DC had always provided leonis
with 27 cops around the arena to keep
his Patron safe until recently now they
provide three how many other things have
trended that way in the relationship
moving the teams will be devastating to
pen quarter it would be crushing to the
city well it's telling that as yunan was
finalizing the terms of his big get
Bowser was hobnobbing with the Elites at
the climate Summit in Dubai so she
arrives back in DC to the bad news all
she offers with the typical liberal
platitudes we know that in our city we
have been through very good times the
best of times and some tough times and
some of those times are ripples in our
history that we always overcome uh we
know that DC fans and DC residents are
are loyal uh and that they are
disappointed today as am I oh you think
they're disappointed oh that makes it
all better and for all her Bluster DC is
in the shape it's in because of the
policies and the politicians that she's
supported a bloated bureaucracy Low
Police recruitment and morale
covid lockdowns that were never
necessary of course led to still empty
Office Buildings and DC's deficit will
be 1.7 billion dollars over five years
and the good mayor calls this all a
perfect storm to explain it away okay
then my question to her is why hasn't
this perfect storm hit Nashville and
Miami why are they
booming the Press tries to act like our
populist movement is somehow hostile to
cities but I'm telling you tonight the
opposite is true we tried and the angle
tried in every way possible to warn
people what would happen if they
continued these insane policies but they
did not listen and Trump he's a New
Yorker of course he doesn't want to see
New York go down the drain and last year
Dan santis won Miami Dade County by
double digits so his policies and that
urban area and suburban area are
working we all want to see all of
America including our beautiful cities
flourish it's the left that's doing
everything they can to destroy them and
that's the angle hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else